all right it's always nice to end the
show with one last bit of happiness I
found on social media this is what I'm
[Music]
liking I'm super passionate about
getting my kids to read and they like it
and now and here they are this morning
yep that's how like you walk in their
room and they were reading to each other
and I was like look I didn't completely
screw up uh but not all kids have
someone outside school pushing them to
pick up books that's why a former New
York teacher is filling hundreds of
barber shops Coast to Coast with reading
materials that Peak kids minds and
creative thinking which is super
important it's a great initiative to
highlight as we prepare for giving
Tuesday from Barber Shop books Let's
everybody say hello to Alvin watching on
NBC new New
York hi Alin oh we have several of those
books in my house my kids love Captain
Underpants so so tell everybody what
this is and and origin story of it
Barber Shop book's mission is to inspire
black boys and other vulnerable children
to read for fun and also to identify as
readers um we create child-friendly
reading spaces uh in uh black barber
shops and other barber shops across the
country and we provide early literacy
training to Barbers about 10 years ago I
was uh getting a haircut across the
street from the school where I taught
first grade and one of my students you
know came into to the barber shop and he
got a little antsy looked a little bored
and I just kept thinking oh I wish I had
a children's book to give him and so you
know understanding the cultural
significance of the barber shop inspired
me to create Barber Shop books I love it
man so this is more than about reading
it's about Community right yeah for many
black boys they have limited access to
black male reading Role Models less than
2% of teachers are black males and a
majority of boys black boys are raised
by single mother uh and so there's a
lack of reading Role Models at school
and at home but they go to the once or
twice a month and so you know it creates
this unique opportunity to promote
reading yeah it's an interesting space
to read it and what a smart thing too
because yeah we're always taking our
kids to get the haircuts that's awesome
for them to be able to do that just
instead of just like the coloring
section you know it's very cool thank
you Alvin this is such a cool initiative
I'm liking your post right now
right all right everybody that's not all
our season long partner pilot pin makers
of friction the go-to race pin of the
Kelly Clarks Jo went to celebrate those
creating another generation of readers
just like you so they're giving Barber
Shop books $1,000 just to help out with
material thanks I appreciate it thank
you Alvin and thank you to all our
guests this hour Kevin Bacon AO Lo
Lauren Shion and Kevin Quinn youall have
a great day and if it's not try and
change
[Applause]
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home